it's not baseball a Red Sox you and I
both Bostonians Red Sox are out of it if
the Dodgers playoffs you gonna go to
those games yeah I'm actually I'm
excited for the Pirates and the Orioles
just cuz they haven't been in it for a
while but I don't baseball I know it's
not quite the way it used to be I don't
like that whole thing like when you go
to a game if you catch a foul ball you
got to like give it to a kid now what
are you talking about that's why kids
are all mushy and fat they don't have to
work for anything so I don't like when I
was a kid I had to fight adults to try
and get one and I never got one and they
boxed me out and that was totally
acceptable in the 70s and 80s yes so now
are they gonna sit there take a line
shot to my hand have that swollen up and
then I give it to a kid do you think
that's why kids are fat in this country
and mushy you really go to be something
but also you know what the new stadiums
they don't make you can't make the
stairs and steep anymore it's a fire
hazard you got them you gotta make them
go out more right and that's another
thing you know in our day we had to
climb to climb once and you had to you
had to burn calories getting the hotdogs
and all that crap now you know you got a
nice easy Coast out there yeah use just
what how many groups are gonna give me
over this one you know all the way
end all right I'm into fat shaming
too
you're the fat how that's how I
stay in shape I like fat che myself like
whenever I get you know get like 1015
over I just stare at myself in the
mirror just thrashing myself just gonna
look at you you piece of but what
you're saying look what you did no one's
gonna love you love you and that works
for you yeah yeah it's working all right
you